[Music]
foreign
's guidance she slowly eases into her
new life at param bill
with every passing day she feels the
home she left behind fade
which makes her longing more acute she
doesn't want to forget
after breakfast kangama says
today I thought we can make Jackfruit
halwa together because Jojo and I are
craving it
JoJo claps his hands
mole the sweetness of life is sure in
only two things love and sugar
if you don't get enough of the first
have more of the second
tangama has already boiled pieces of
jackfruit
and now she mashes them with melted
jaggery
here's a secret
as you mash the Jackfruit close your
eyes and think of something you want
from your husband
screws her eyes shut grinning from the
effort and showing off the gap between
her front teeth
now a pinch of cardamom salt and a
teaspoon of ghee ready it must cool more
now taste it isn't it wonderful
she lowers her voice I'm serious bully
this is the key to a happy marriage make
your wish and then feed your husband
this halva whatever you want will come
true
her pride in getting into the rhythm of
the household of making a few dishes
under tangama's watchful eye is undercut
by the knowledge that tangama must soon
leave
lavishly Praises her chicken curry She
Glows with pride
but in the next moment she finds herself
clinging to tangamma burying her face on
that well-padded shoulder to hide her
tears
please stay never leave
but already she loves tangama too much
to say it
tangama has her own house to run a
husband who awaits her
she mumbles I will never forget your
kindness how can I ever thank you
[Music]
ah when you have a daughter-in-law treat
her like a jewel
that's how you can thank me
[Music]